they work in secret and under constant
threat reporting on the depredations of
isis in their home city some have fled
in fear for their own lives even in
exile they are in no way safe
[Music]
[Applause]
we walk through this horn means to
combat the dark forces will carry out a
graffiti conveyance on the walls inside
the most dangerous strongholds of Isis
attempting to prove to the world that we
will defeat arms with thoughts
[Music]
members of ruckus ba is being sorta
silent we are no different from any one
of you we love our home and we have
ambitions and dreams of raising a family
and leaving happy
[Music]
I'm deeply sad for my beautiful country
a suffering greatly from raging fever
and the cancer of tourism so greatly
that I feel its separate will man
[Music]